now while the Republicans continue to
turn up the heat on the bias and the
Russia investigation of course the media
and the Liberals they're doing their
best to change the subject by attacking
President Trump watch this the key word
in all of this that he keeps using is
tainted there's only one institution
that really has been tainted through
these months and that is the Trump
presidency
you've got him attacking the judiciary
you have him attacking the CIA you have
him attacking the Department of Justice
the FBI I mean this is the conduct of
someone who could become a tyrant if we
don't step in and speak out against him
the FBI is a key part of the fair and
transparent legal process that defines
our democracy so every time the
president tweets against the FBI or
tweets against the Department of Justice
he's making the Russians job a lot
easier
joining us with reaction to all of this
Salem nationally syndicated radio is
larry elder former press secretary for
vice president Brent pence Mark Lauder
and Fox News legal analyst Greg jarred
here with me in the studio Greg I want
to go to you first and take off of what
congressman Biggs said the reason they
elicited you've been very clear in your
writings about the law on this and how
this investigation was started here but
this started as I said about as a
counterintelligence running in operation
to find out what the Russians did do you
think we're gonna get back to that point
and how can we get back to the well the
entire set of investigations are all
based on one fictitious document this
dossier was used to launch the Trump
Russia investigation we had noted by
director Comey in the end which which
then morphed into the Muller
investigation it was also used
apparently for a FISA warrant to spy on
the Trump campaign so if it turns out
that after a year and a half the FBI and
the Department of Justice can't verify
the authenticity or contents of the
dossier then what you have is inherently
a fraudulent investigation
what struck me about what the
congressman said is James commis role in
all of this he may have committed
several crimes not only in converting
government property for his own use in
leaking it to trigger the investigation
by robert muller but you will find out I
guarantee this the James Comey also had
a direct role in selecting his longtime
friend and Ally and and former partner
Robert Muller which is unconscionable
since Comey is a key witness in the case
in any potential obstruction so there's
an ethical issue as well yeah all right
so so one quick question Greg before we
bring the rest of the panel in yes or no
whether James Comey used a personal
laptop or a government laptop is it
still the same violation it is that he
was acting in the course of the scope of
his job as FBI director when he wrote it
it is government property it's not his
he's not allowed to take it with him and
there are pretty significant reports
that although seven presidential memos
are classified materials which means
that Comey taking them home is a crime
just like Hillary Clinton committed
crimes in my judgment by having 110
classified emails on her home personal
unauthorized unsecured server all right
let's bring the panel back in on this in
full view Larry good to see you mark
good to see you Larry let me go out to
the west coast I mean the politics of
this is there the media we talked about
that that aspect is there but the
Republicans have to come together and
launch a true investigative process
you've do a lot of political analysis do
you see them doing this or do you see
the typical Washington commission that
postures as they go through their time I
think David at this point there's been
so much as Donald Trump put it taint on
this investigation that most Republicans
right now are content to let the thing
play out all of these problems regarding
the biased people they're involved in
the investigation this phony dossier
that the Greg was talking about let the
thing play out Republicans are not going
to believe it
Democrats already want him impeached in
the
sort of in the middle you're not gonna
find two-thirds senators willing to
throw Donald Trump out of the office in
the unlikely event the Democrats take
over the house and impeach them so let
it go let Donald Trump stick to the
knitting which is to get this economy
humming along at 4% GDP and in 2020
he'll be overwhelmingly reelected I
think that's how most Republicans are
playing this right now and I think it's
and I think it's a perfectly valid and
sensible way of playing it let it play
out all right let's take it right inside
the White House or a former in this case
mark you and I've talked about this on
my radio show a host of topics looking
at it from the administration's point of
view and you've been there for both
POTUS and v POTUS how do you take this
if you're the administration how do you
approach this do you let it play out as
a Larry said absolutely the White House
continues to cooperate fully with the
special counsel through all of that
process and they're looking forward to
this being done in a expeditious fashion
but one of the key things that we've
also found out here just recently and
some very good reporting by The
Washington Post was that the Obama
administration knew years ago about the
warning signs that were developing of
what Russia was planning to do how they
were planning to attack election
integrity with with cyber warfare and
they did nothing about it so here's once
again another case where the feckless
leadership of the former administration
led to the problems that Donald Trump is
having to clean up as president whether
its funding Hezbollah through cocaine
and turning the blind eye to that now
we've got them looking the other way on
this just shows you the Democrats don't
have a message this is all a witch-hunt
to cover President Obama's failures all
right guys let's go around the table I'm
going to go back to Greg Jarrett I
always look to you for the legal aspects
of this and you know mark just mentioned
something the extension of this if they
find out that there was undue influence
exerted by the administration or with
some 30 agencies is being reported by
political of all things involved in this
operation project Cassandra are these
adjunct to this investigation don't
expect robert muller to prosecute his
longtime friend James Comey or anybody
within the FBI of which Mulder used to
be the director this requires a second
special counsel if it turns out that
people for political reasons senior
management in the FBI to some extent of
the Department of Justice fixed it so
Hillary Clinton was absolved and then
went after Donald Trump targeting him as
the so-called insurance policy launching
a fraudulent investigation against him
all of that would constitute arguably
obstruction of justice by several people
that demands don't count on Jeff
Sessions to do this it requires and
demands a second special counsel all
right so back to larry elder Larry on
the politics of this on the extension on
the expansion of this investigation I
keep cutting back to how do we narrow
this back to the issue and bring out the
bad actors in charge them and you know
my friend III again I am skeptical of
the ability of Washington to focus given
the deep state existence of many in the
top echelon and this is not about the
line agents this is suits versus boots
and the suits and the political that
have been made permanent I think that's
where a lot of this problem lies well
this is all about the allegation that
Trump is in bed with Putin the person
that ought to be we ought to be looking
at in terms of being in bed with Putin
is Barack Obama one of Obama's first
acts as president was to ditch the deal
that George HW Bush had negotiated for a
defense of Poland and the Czech Republic
because he wanted to curry favor with
the Russians to do the Iran deal it was
Obama on that hot Michael told Medvedev
that after the election I have more
flexibility it was Obama who slammed
Mitt Romney for suggesting that Russia
was a big geopolitical problem so if
anybody wants to talk about who was
cozying up with with Russia and with
Putin we ought to be talking about Obama
not Trump all right so mark we can't go
back in time unfortunately we can talk
about it we can look into actions taken
by the previous administration we can
look at Project Cassandra we can look at
all of this but you know you've got to
move the ball forward on this and does
examine in the Obama administration's
actions
bring us any closer to exposing what's
going on inside the deep state within
the liberal quarters or the Washington
quarters of the bureaucratic quarters
obviously if you're going if you're
gonna if you're going to influence
elections or come up with insurance
policies that needs to be looked at
because there could be an I'll trust
Greg on that if there's potential
criminality there but meanwhile the
president the vice president the entire
White House they're focused on doing the
job of the American people they've got
tax cuts done those that money's going
to be in people's pockets in a couple of
months next it's on to immigration
infrastructure and possibly even
entitlement reform there's a lot on the
table the president's not even he's just
barely getting started right now and so
they'll keep focused on that and we'll
leave the history and looking for
criminality to those who do it best
all right gentlemen Greg mark Larry
thank you so much there's a lot more we
know this is only the beginning of a new
line not just a new year coming up thank
you very much